R
CRACK .WE'LL AN
WHO EDGHANISGHAN RS D
HE             HAFT WHAT'S  SAYT
R THE LAST W
IGENCE,
PLANNING, EXECUTION, OR
JUDGME CHOICE,
GEORGE.
WHEN THE TALIB -- LE
AY.
OU HAD THE
COUNTRY,N E  THE LEADET NT GET
SIGNIFANT COLLAPSETHE
AFGHS AD
HAPPENED.OEM, JUSTR D TAKINGAS
AT'SIM HAPPENED.
>> WE'VEALL SEEN THE
WE'VEDS OF PEOED INTO A C-17.
>> THAT WAS FIVEAY
>> WHADID YOU TH
FIRST SATHOSE PICTURESHAT I THO
GAIN CONTROL OF THIS
MO QUICKLY, WE HAVE
AIRPORT,
AND WE YOU DON'T THINK TCOHAVE N
NOTAKES?
I DON'T THINK IT COULDE
HANDLED IN AAYRE
T T ING, I D KAT IN HINDT OKT TO
>>R YOAS ALWAYS NTO THCISION?
ESS PRICED INTO THDECISION.
CNN'S KYLIE ATWOOD IS AT THE
STATE PAE  START WITH CNN'S
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
WHAT BIDEN HAS BEE
RECENT WEEKS BECAUSE HE HAS
>> YEAH, JAKE.Y DID.EY DID HEFG
I'M A LILE SURPRISED
LAST COMMERE SAYING THAT
HEID THERE COULD
BE ARAWDOW HAPPEN WITHOUT CHAO
HPRE  W FROM
THE LAST SEVER MONTHS AND
ESPEALLAST SEVERAL
DAYS IS THAT THEY HAVE BEEVEENC
DATING BACK TO THAT JULY 8thCE
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN. WAS G OWTHE
FRAMINED IL THAT THIS
IS THE DECISIOTH
GOING .
HE DID NOT SAY BK IN APRIL AND
BACK IJULY IDIY CHTI
OWRA
QUOTES FROM THE PRESIDENT
ON THIS IS GOING
HOW THOSE ANSWERS THERE ARHARD E
GOING TO SATISFY A LOT OE
ES OF THIS
WHITE HOUSE OR MAJOR U.S. ALLI
TH CRITICAL OF THED EXIT HE
DOWN AE LAST DAYS
AND JUST POINT OF FACT I'L
NOTEWHF HE WAS TALKING ABOUT TH
WDEDITMANY PPLT MILITARYWAS LEA
AIRPORT IN, THAT WAS
ONDAY.
AND THE PRESEN FOUAYS AGO.
PIC
FROM
>> OURREGRND
REPORTEDS BY
RED INTOIS THERE ANY SENSE OF AD
OF ORGIZED EFFORT T NOW AT
THE AIRPORT TO PITIZ
G TAAFGHANS WHO ARE IN THEE
FOE L IMMIGRANFGHANISTAN?
T WE'RE WA I
STATE  TRY AND APPLY SOME SORT
CONTROL RIG.PROGRAM,SE
MS TE AFS FGHANIST W HELPED
THE UNITED STATEIT WASN'T A PRO
IN KE
NOW.
SO, WHAT THE STATE DEPARTMEN
IORITIZE SOME OL, THOSE HA
THE AIRPORT AND TRY AND GET ON
THIGHTS.
ANY AMERICAN W IIN THECOUNTRY,
COME SERVE ONCE THEY GET
TO THE AIRPORT
BUT OF COURSE OBLEMSRE, GETTINGE
ARTMENT SA
REPORTS OF THERE BEING ISSUES
ASSAGE TO THORT.
THEY ARE SAYING THE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PUSH THEM
TOBUT  TELLINGICANS TH TT ASSURE
EM TO T  THEAF
GSO THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTI
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS SAYINGAA
THROUGHHE THA
BUT THIS IS A SITUATION THAT IS
ENT BY MOMENT. THIS IS SOMETHIN
EY ARE KEEPIHESURGINRESOURCES T
SOONER.ND, ITRESIDENTVEG
AYS.
HE WANTS TO TALKBO
ON T ALL U.S.
TR FRE
THAN HE WANTS TOW
THIS WITHDRAWAL NEW
T THE EXIT HASEEN.
HELY TOLD HANOPOULOS THIS WAS
D  DECISD THE  STILLUT BUT TALI
COUNTRY ISY UNLIKELY.
THAT WAS LASMONT
>> YEAH,T A FEW WEEKS AGO.
AND PART OGEORGE'S QUEST
THERE WAS NGN  FAILURE.
AND I THINATETHING
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE WANTE
HAVE BEEN, WHAT WERE
U HEG TH
LIKELIHOOD AND Y JUST
HEED THAT
WHATE E S KERMAN THE
SAYING THERE WAS UP BY
NOT PREDICT WHATARE NOTHE OTHER
BIDEN HIMSELF ADMITTED THAT TH
HAEDASD.HAT DOES RAISE AOT
OF QUESTIONS AT SE AINRONG AND
HAS BE BEEN HESITANT TO SA
PUBLICLY.
THEY BELIEVED IT WLD OR
CERTAINLY HOPED THAT IT WOULD.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
ISSUES WITH THE BESTD
AND THE ADJUSTMENT
BUT NO ONE HASAS A IN FOCUSING
CLTHE
TOPRESIDOVER THE LAST SEVERADAY.
HE IS DEFIANT OVER HOW THIS ISTE
MI SETOR
FOR U.STROOPSCOMPLETELY ONCE
GET TO KABUL OT BY
TH? ID  THA
SPOKE ABOUT WITH THE
RT EARLIER TODAY.
BA THAT EYERL ICS
THAT THEY EWINWEREN'T GOING WEL
WERE WARNING THOE OUO GET EY ARO
APO G
PRIORI GET TO THETE FLIGHTS
OUT OF THE
ASSURESAE E
NITELY GOING
ITA F THE E COUNTRY.
REALITY RIGHT NOW,HICH IS THAT
AN IN THE ISNBL AT THEY ARE INT
COUNTRY BY VIRTUE OF THET
RAM ESNTIALL
AMERICANS
THEMSELVES TO GET IN TOUCHH
THE STATE PAATTHEY EVEN T
>> AND ACCORDINGNATE
CESTRATION
IEFED SEAID T TS OF Y THAN KTH
AIR BRS,HICH IS, I A
A RS. THANK YOU
LET'S BR DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN OF
ARINE
HE'S NOW A MAJOR IN THRESERVES.
AFGHANISTANESIDENT BIDEDECISIO
CONG SO MU
FOR JOUS.
ITAVE YOU ON THESHOWGET YOUR RE
PRESIDENT BIDEN TELLINSTEPHANOP
DECISION, THAT HE ALWANES G
THINGS WERE  BE BAD.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> THANKS FOE ON
JAKE.
WHHI OFFICE,
HE WRENCHING DECISN. GO BIG OR .
HE COULD DOUBLE DOWN AND RAMP UP
THN A ENCE BY ANENTER OF MAGNI
OR HE COULD MAKE THEHIGH.
NOW, WITL  COUNTRY
OF EMPIRES WAS NEVER GOING TO B
ADMINISTRATION RESUME BOTH
COMMERCIALNDITARY
EVACUATIONS HE
AB AIRPORT.
>> SU AGRETHGOOM
AND HARE NOT
CHAOS?
E FOCUSED
A LOT ON TALIBANR
AND E D OF THEIR ADVANCE
BUT OTE
AFGHAN WPOWER.
RSON ARMY WITH A
N A
MATT